الهجرة ليست ظاهرة جديدة ، إنها
ظاهرة قديمة
ولها علاقة
بعاملين سحب ودفع ،
يؤسفني أن أقول ذلك ، لكننا نشعر أن
بيلاروسيا تستخدم هؤلاء المهاجرين كأداة سياسية
ضد
الاتحاد الأوروبي والدول الأوروبية
في الواقع  أجرينا
مناقشات مختلفة
مع
وزير الخارجية الليتواني مع وزير خارجية
بولس مع جميع
وزراء الاتحاد الأوروبي تقريبًا حول هذه المسألة
لا يمكننا منع شعبنا من السفر إلى
الخارج
حتى يكونون أحرارًا وهذا
وفقًا لدستورنا
ولكن
عند وصولهم إلى هناك  في مينسك
نشعر أن هناك بعض
المنظمات هناك وينظمون
لها من
أجل إيصالهم إلى الحدود
ومن ثم
في التهريب لدينا هذه
المشكلة هناك مجرمون
ومهربون داخل العراق
في
بيلاروسيا وفي دول أخرى
ينظمون هذه الأشياء لذلك
نحن في  مناقشة مع الاتحاد الأوروبي
أيضا ونحن نحاول السيطرة على
هذا في الواقع
لم نسمح برحلات جوية للعراق من بغداد
نحن نمنع ذلك
، والآن تركيا تفعل الشيء نفسه ،
لذلك دعونا نأمل في
أن نتوصل إلى حل لأنه
في النهاية
يجب ألا
يتم استخدام الإنسان كأدوات
لتحقيق أهداف سياسية لبعض الدول
للضغط على الاتحاد الأوروبي
يمكنهم ذلك  استخدام
أنواع أخرى من
الوسائل ولكن ليس استخدام
أه اللاجئين وخاصة اللاجئين من
العراق الآن نحن نتحدث عن العراق لذلك
الآلاف منهم موجودون
هناك وهو وضع مروع
أه نحاول حله نحن
نتواصل مع اللاجئين
أنفسهم  أو
هؤلاء
المهاجرين أه لإعادتهم إلى
العراق فهذه سياستنا هي
التحدث إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي في
محاولة لإقناع
هؤلاء الناس بالعودة إلى
بلدهم وفي نفس الوقت
إعطاء
إشارات للحكومة في مينسك بأن هذا ليس
النهج الصحيح